بكم من جديد البدايه بما حصلت الجزيره
عليه من تفاصيل رد حركه حماس على مقترح
اتفاق التهدئه في غزه الذي قدمته للوسطاء
وتضمن موافقه على اطار اتفاق يرمي الى
تطبيق هدنه تامه ومستدام على ثلاث مراحل
تستغرق كل مرحله منها 45 يوما وتشمل
التوافق على تبادل الاسرى والجثمان وانهاء
الحصار واعاده اعمار القطاع واضافت
المصادر ان حماس طالبت بالانتهاء من
مباحثات التهدئه التامه قبل بدء المرحله
الثانيه وضمان خروج القوات الاسرائيليه من
حدود القطاع وبدء عمليه الاعمار وفقا
للمقترح فقد عرضت حماس في المرحله الاولى
اطلاق سراح المحتجزين الاسرائيليين من
النساء والاطفال والمسلمين والمرضى مقابل
1500 اسير بينهم 500 من اصحاب الاحكام
المؤبده والاحكام العاليه كما اشترطت حماس
ادخال ما لا يقل عن 500 شاحنه يوميا من
المساعدات والوقود الى القطاع خلال
المرحله الاولى وطلبت ايضا بعوده النازحين
الى اماكن سكنهم وضمان حريه حركتهم وفتح
المعابر كما تضمن رد حماس ضروره الموافقه
على ادخال ما لا يقل عن 60 الف مسكن مؤقت
و 200 ال خيمه
خلال المرحله الاولى واشترطت اقرار خطه
اعمار المنازل والمنشات الاقتصاديه
والمرافق العامه المدمره خلال مده لا
تتجاوز ثلاث سنوات كذلك اشتمل الرد وقف
اقتحام المستوطنين للاقصى وعوده الاوضاع
في المسجد الاقصى الى اوضاع ما قبل عام
2002 طالبت حماس ايضا ان تكون كل من قطر
ومصر والولايات المتحده الامريكيه تركيا
وروسيا اطرافا ضامنه لتنفيذ هذا
الاتفاق